hey I told you previously about that new
state law in California which gets rid
of the ability to use a personal or
religious exemption for vaccination for
families that don't want their kids to
be vaccinated but want them to go to
public schools the new law which was
signed into law by Democratic governor
jerry brown says that students entering
the to checkpoint year so they check for
this in kindergarten and seventh grade
you have to show proof of vaccination ok
and if you transfer into the school
system at say second grade you also have
to show proof of vaccinations at that
time school started a few days ago in
California in some parts of California
and a whole bunch of Sacramento students
were sent home because they showed up
for kindergarten in seventh grade with
no proof of vaccinations in the false
false on Cordova Unified School District
out of 3200 students starting
kindergarten hundred and forty-five were
sent home sorry that's kindergarten and
seventh grade both of the checkpoint
years hundred and forty-five were sent
home because they didn't have
immunization records of the 145 sent
home on the first day of school
forty-seven got their paperwork or got
their vaccinations in order within the
next three days 98 were still out three
days later and this always gets us back
to the sort of the same talking points
which is vaccinations have actually been
required in California schools going all
the way back to nineteen sixty two
nothing has changed as far as that goes
what's changed is you can no longer say
my religion makes it so I don't want
vaccines thus my kid needs to go to the
school anyway even though they're not
vaccinated uh the difference now is you
can't get an exemption for religious
reasons which makes sense if we're
talking about a public health scenario
and number two there's the argument that
the government is mandating people get
vaccines no they're not they're just
saying if you want to send your kids to
public schools you need to have the
vaccines and part of this is not lack of
vaccination part of it is lack of access
to the records we don't have a
nationalized electronic medical record
system so if you
move uh after first grade and you go
into second grade somewhere else you
might not have those records so part of
this is logistical it's not that a lot
of these kids are unvaccinated a lot
simply don't have the records I don't
buy for a second that the government is
mandating vaccinations they're just
saying we set up schools we set up rules
for those schools and here is what they
are if you choose to send your kids to
these schools that's it yeah yeah and if
the government were to mandate
vaccinations I take it we'd both be
against it uh rights yeah I don't know I
mean yeah it strikes me as um unless it
gets to a point where the entire country
is is facing a huge crisis because of
lack of that but I mean we're nowhere
near that I've not taken a position writ
large about forced vaccination mean
generally speaking I'm against forced
medical procedures that's my instinct
right uh and the way it's being looked
at which is okay most kids go to public
school these are the rules for public
school if you want to set set up an
institution and the kids aren't
vaccinated that sort of up to you would
my view change if unvaccinated children
uh became so prevalent that they were
regularly causing even more outbreaks
than we've already seen them cause I
don't know I don't want to take an
emotional position on it and i really
want to think it through more i'd be
interested in hearing from people who
are both for and/or against mandatory
vaccinations period which is not what is
happening in california